Let's dig into some of the details of the DHT technology. The first name-space
that the DHT technology has to deal with is the key-space name-space.
So the way name-space is managed is, if you have content to
disseminate. You generate, a unique key, for the content,
by using some algorithm like SHA1 which generates a
160-bit key. The number of bits in the key or the signature is big enough that
they will not recollision even if different content
are using the same algorithm to generate this key.
So that is how you create a unique
signature for a particular content, using SHA-1. The second
name-space we have to deal with is a
node-space. So here, what we're doing is, we are
creating an SHA-1 hash of IP addresses of nodes that want to share content.
So, let's say that me and my buddies. Form a social network and all our IP
addresses, we going to use this algorithm to
encode them into this 160-bit node id. So
now we've got two name-spaces, one is the
key-space, name-space and the node-space, name-space, and both
of them are derived using the same algorithmic
technique, let's say. So in this case we've
created a key for the content so that
there's a unique signature for a particular content,
similarly, we've created a node id from the
IP address, which is again a unique signature
for a particular IP address. The objective is, if I have a key, I want to store.
That key in a node id N, such that the key is very close to the node id
N. Ideally, if you're lucky, the key is exactly
equal to N, but, you know, it's not possible
to guarantee that this hash and this hash will
result in exactly the same value. So long as
it is close enough, like in the previous example
I showed you. That if I generated a hash 149,
I stored it in that node 150, which is
close enough to the hash that I created. So the
API for manipulating this distibuted hash table data structure would
be putkey and getkey, so putkey would take two arguments.
The key and the value. Value can be anything
that you want to associate with that. In the previous
example, I've said the value may be the IP address
of the content that is associated with the particular key.
And getkey takes one argument, namely the key, and
returns the value that is associated with that key-value pair.